hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within the
executioner DLC now we're gonna read
this file here eliminate test subject
the detective your daughter's memory
degradation is slowed but stem
domination of the remaining subjects has
progressed steadily
the only subject confirmed to be still
be in the house is CB 204 the detective
access to corresponding area oh except
AXA
access the corresponding area and kill
the detective at this time we are unable
to say definitively the that the death
of a test subject in the subsequent
removal of their influence leads
directly to memory preservation the
possibility exists that an unknown
element is affecting the integrity of
subject memories must observes the girls
movement patterns and be watchful for
unanticipated phenomena okay that seemed
a little convoluted and I have no idea
what you're talking about
but I'm gonna keep playing because I
like it and I have and we're exploring
like what were what we're actually doing
here is we're exploring like the baser
part of what the evil within us and like
the system that exists and evil within
universe which is interesting by itself
I do want a bit more though okay since I
like to hammer so much I might as well
upgrade this one then good for me can I
increase walking ah I'm just short I
could do this though alright good enough
for me I'm not gonna do many of the
optional things unless I absolutely need
to I mean I need to find a place to be
able to heal oh look it's a Healey do
how perfect for me thank you okay so I
need to go upstairs I guess that's just
like an endless thing where I could farm
money if I really needed to but I don't
think there's a need to I mean for the
most part it's just like kill kill wham
wam don't be suck hey don't be suck I
said purpose I like a teleport you I saw
an eye bail flying they're rare okay so
I remember this
I got ambushed here quite a few times so
now it's castellano Manos hello thank
you for the heal anything here Oh money
cool buns I just like spam my orange
mind blasts everywhere I go
because there could be like hidden
doodads then maybe not show off on
everything that I was doing before oh I
see the long hallway here we go huh
that's a weird one
what am I looking at like a pit of Hell
style thing oh hey how's it going
oh I'm not gonna squish you you're my
furry little friend
goodbye [ __ ] smart Marv Melinda was
that the name Mar Mar Mar Mar Mar
Melinda the mouse oh yeah nope not
destructible okay not there all right
enough wandering around like a ninny oh
hey how's it going ready to die no it's
so brutal well who else is here oh hey
you came to the best party just in time
I don't know why you volunteered to do
this but hey here you are boy he was not
war he was not over there yeah it
doesn't matter so long as it keeps it
fresh and original I'm okay with that
bang owner how long until I actually
keep my identity and I wonder how they
were able to actually put me in the like
body of this dude and that also begs the
question of who this dude was in the
first place like why was he here in the
system because this is after rubra cop
see Marv Marv Melinda are you leading me
all Marv Melinda you're such a cutie
patootie thank you you warned me of the
impending doom
okay that guy's gone Wonka Rooney okay
that's not as happy as I was hoping it
to be Marv Marv Melinda I'm alright the
guy with glasses didn't look like anyone
I should be talking to I can still hear
his laughter in my head I don't think he
knew who he was anymore I think the
trick to keeping my mind together is to
think about all the stuff I'm going to
do when I get out of here the guy with
the glasses sounds like Jojo but I don't
like that he's maniacally laughing do I
have to do I have to fight Jojo again
how much get my heart take I'm not ready
for this
okay found the hidden door good I hope I
don't have to fight Jojo again Oh Jojo
no no oh no that's so sad
that's song come on when I was gone
where I was gone why I was gone I am
alone painful painful where's my arm
kill kill oh wow oh that's so sad why do
I have to kill Jojo I don't want to no
no with the Jojo Oh a face for our
detective subject exhibited repeated
loss of self-awareness as well as an
involuntary suicidal tendencies yeah he
kept throwing himself off a bridge as
hanging through my head it's okay we
count at least for a tense subject also
showed repeated interment at physical
deformation subjects initial recovery is
reverse course and at present he was
lost self awareness inflow of
consciousness from other subjects his
component of stem domination subjects of
memories appear to be disorganized in
the linguistic ability minimal I don't
want to I don't want to he's too cool oh
all right fine
I'll do it as a mercy cuz obviously he's
in pain I must be the one to end
Joseph's pain wait I keep hearing other
dudes you have a gun this doesn't
exactly make it fair for me where'd you
go alright fine
Jojo you want to go go oh hey dude that
didn't hurt you at all you missed me
whoa you're uh you're tougher than I
thought you'd be whoa hey okay
seem to be doing blow away what's that
okay not run run run run he looks like
he might have been a little below
turning is not my strong suit
I need one of those upgrades for speed
it's obviously not working for me okay
where'd you go where'd you go oh he's
over there okay
poor Jojo I don't want to do this oh
good thing I didn't like execute I might
hate to actually see like how that would
go down Oh No
please be better Jojo oh no no
intentionally doing this to me they're
intentionally making me feel bad
damn it good I guess if you go faster
now this is good I guess that's a lot of
blood oh man
follow your daughter okay I guess I'll
follow my daughter I'm all sad now I'm
sad now I mean as Kidman I fought him
before and it didn't like kill him kill
him and then she shot him and apparently
that killed him but that didn't kill him
kill him so maybe he's still alive just
keep that in mind okay I'll save it for
standard upgrades you seem to be doing
good so far hopefully I'll be a little
faster now and then wait there was still
like one more area up there wasn't there
like on the right here I didn't go that
way it is open hello someone here
well besides these dead people I mean
they're not dead yet well practically up
against me thank you okay
so what's up here besides a movie all
right then so what's up here besides
another bonus anything good anything in
the wardrobe can I go to Narnia is that
it no okay
oh that looks bad I should probably
throw something into that know that
cheers to nice obviously can i Crouch
under it
yeah well my big safe face doesn't blast
on that okay we're good
hello Marmol are Melinda you remind me
of jojo with your best game so brutal
Marv Marv Melinda show me the way show
me a secret place where JoJo's still
alive
yay money I guess oh that's a cool
painting I suppose all right then Marv
Melinda wait for me you'll wait for me
right right Marv Marv Melinda Oh bang
anybody here want this woo
Whitney whoa Bo oh oh hey how's it going
how did I get here anyway I think I try
to think but I can't remember I think it
was therapy but dad and I fought about
it he said that Rueben guy might be able
to help me but he didn't trust him but I
had to try wow man you went to Reuben
okay so ah Marv Marv Melinda
leading me to secrets I like it Marv
Marv Melinda come on come on Marv Marv
Melinda oh what a good mousy moe what a
good little mousy moe boink
thank you okay was that it oh no I guess
not must have been it I'll be on my way
thank you my dear friends were giving me
money I think I'll be able to buy
another speed upgrade again and I think
actually this is the back path because
both of these doors probably led to the
same area so I'm just operating under
the assumption that's not gonna lead me
anywhere new because this is where the
door yeah that's where the door was okay
so this has leads back to the place I
was so I can go this way now but I did
find a little bit extra so that was cool
and all but now I must go and save my
daughter Oh can't die on this I can't
shave my daughter if I get blown just me
the rules ja sure George er oh that's
that's fancy oh that's fun this house is
nice
yes Suzie's the one for taxidermy I'm
not I'm not exactly for taxidermy not
morally I just die creeps me out in many
ways mostly just cuz I have a fear of
mannequins and they're kind of like
animal mannequins
yeah that's pretty creepy hello daughter
whoa that's a big portal oh oh no
they'll probably an upgrade point cuz
they've done that before
daughter no why did you go into this
giant portal ah the big swirling purple
design are you oh boy hallway this is
the least thing that I expected big I
will not stop in my quest to save my
daughter yeah I think we'll get a byway
except for this piece of paper right
here damn I read hello what was my
doctor doing here I saw him walking down
the hall thanks for the input daughter
extremely helpful in my questioning a
view I wonder if I'll have to fight the
spider lady thing because this kind of
looks like this arrow that was the thing
that happened good I get to rip my own
what the hell whoa what the hell just
happened okay
are we still okay I don't know what just
happened but for some reason my web
browser opened up for no reason
okay I'm under the assumption that we're
back now so here we go crack smack cut
floor flee okay happy birthday
Mazel Tov I remember I got embarrassed
in like seventh grade when I was doing a
reading cuz I mean I had it I had a nice
voice for eating but uh I didn't know
what Mazel Tov was Mazel Tov Mazel Tov I
don't know Mom I still don't know what
it is but when I read it I read it as
Mazel Tov and everyone laughed at me and
laughed at me and I was no pain I'll
make them pay the lumbering behemoth I
actually wonder how long this DLC is
because there aren't many subjects left
in here with me I think it was just
seven total and I had me and my daughter
count as two separate ones so that only
leaves four people and I've already
killed three of them oh no sorry five
people I'm bad at math only I only took
up to calc four I'm terrible at math I
know I must have seen all kinds of scary
things but I can't remember so I don't
feel scared at all she's kidding
dominated by the system I have just a
way override the save oh no I already
saved okay good good good good good
where's that safe well there's no safe
oh there's okay I need to get faster
because there's a lumbering behemoth
need to go quick quickly quickly quickly
that's amazing that I somehow know
exactly what to do in the situation of
when I'm presented with a giant
pulsating safe on the wall I'd like to
think that if I were ever called into a
similar situation where the sudden need
to shove my fist into a pulsating wall
arose pray it never happens to me as
before with the death of CBO 204 the
rate of your daughter's memory loss is
slowed however all other subjects show
more advanced decay than previously
recorded more investigation is necessary
coinciding with this event a pathway to
the heart of the match and Oh at the
heart of the mansion has opened we have
also located CB 205 an ex-soldier CB 205
eradication of remaining test subjects
will leave the girl with the only one to
retain any memories however there's a
strong probability that those memories
will not be intact the approximate
locations of remaining subjects can now
be determined but deterioration of the
memories of the other subjects suggests
that full stem domination of the other
subjects may have occurred the
appearance of this new location within
the manor house suggests I'll link with
the rubic entity and it is believed to
be a residual effect of his presence it
is unknown if any part of his
consciousness is retained within stem
however the girl is now on a linear path
directly out of our observable area
influence of the Rubik and the would
account for this change cross reference
previous Rubik case files as well as
goal of test subjects discerned over
from their individual transcripts I
don't know what any of that means didn't
make a damn bit of sense okey-dokey then
I'm assuming that this portal on the
right is just another one of the bonus
things and this actually leads farther
than the story because as far as I know
I'm doing fairly okay we got here lovely
I don't know what to do I keep
forgetting mom and dad's names it's
happened like five times now I can't
believe I forget something like that
I should tattoo them on my arm it's a
dick don't suck it it's a dick
anyone know what I'm talking about Derek
comedy I have a specific type of memory
loss caused my by my best friend also he
killed my wife but that's not important
most important thing it's our dick no
one no one at all it's like one of my
favorite sketches from early YouTube
done I love Derek comedy great stuff
great stuff
going on here let's our horrible
monstrosity is this okay well this looks
fun how do I not die
seems pretty straightforward so far okay
okay that was easy
well that was fun glad I did that glad
all these heaters here Ruby oh look a
switch conveniently placed behind boxes
that I was gonna break anyway I'm so
much mark I'm so good at this puzzle of
knife so why can't I get in these boxes
either oh okay so that looks trapped
like I don't think I should trust that
I'm not gonna go that way
okay daughter oh I have to go that way
oh hello I need to get to that thank you
plunk all right oh they stopped okay so
far so good
hello hey doctor do you remember my dad
who are you leaving these notes for who
are you talking to I'm your father and
you are listen to me when I'm talking to
you you will follow my instructions
oh it's the big guy with the big iron
bar that's not a euphemism okay RPG RPG
Bom Bom Bom thanks guns
thanks guns lovely great RPG okay you
are going to the heaven the heaven spell
the ATV en this place is like a dream
come true I never seem to get tired here
I can fight forever
these grunts are stupid but they don't
quit if I could get them organized
getting a little sick of these dead
heads I keep blowing them away but more
of them come somebody somewhere is
watching me you won't get the drop on me
I can do anything I want in this place
I'm a rocket-launching fool bring it on
[ __ ] I got ammo out the ass that you
should probably the doctor look at that
it's like there's icicles freezing in my
brain they're trying to take my thoughts
right one of you no one's ever gonna
take me down
who roses and Marines who eyes wait I'm
not gonna say anything that I'm ignorant
to because I might look stupid people
might mock me mercilessly alright okay
RPG scissors I remember you you are a
cool dude and also probably gonna blow
me away so this guy's gonna take a
little bit more strategy than the other
guy haha behind a box you can't get me
whoa Jesus that's not how our peaches
work oh you just gonna stamp this whole
time huh alrighty then
wait so how is that fair oh there are
guys okay oh this is not good okay I'm
gonna get you now I'll got you now oh
that did you do that that's a bunch of
baloney there all right you want some oh
I got a chair and also you got no chance
bang Boinky Boinky back up miss me back
up miss me again
miss me again he got me that time oh
hello you pretty beautiful come back
here please say what he used to chainsaw
Annie because this is taking a while you
wanna you a chainsaw fight
you're dead now I brought up a road
remember - you into the next world thank
you it's surprisingly fun oh I wouldn't
mind a little bit of that in my life
okay anyway hello hello beautiful
eliminate test subjects see b210
psychiatric patient the influence of the
soldier subject has been negated
we have also determined the location of
your daughter as well as your next
target stems domination of your daughter
dramatically accelerated why the moment
she is completely subdued rescue will no
longer be possible you must find and
eliminate the psychiatric patient see
b210 it is unclear if the sudden
acceleration and stem domination is
caused by CB to10 or some artifact of
the ruvik entity there has been
circumstantial evidence of this presence
but nothing has been verified we'll
examine data from the Rubik incident to
support the supposition that reducing
the number of test subjects will bring
one closer to the core erosion of the
girl's memory cannot be avoided but we
are formulating a new hypothesis to
account for the recent developments
transmission is more difficult in the
basements below the mansion there are
two targets left but obtaining accurate
readings is difficult so I'm gonna do
all your dirty work don't worry about me
wait what about the thing that's okay so
daughter went in there but there's a big
pulsating thing on the wall over there
that's good I'm gonna go into the Savi
soo there it is hello thank you
alright so I'm gonna save now and
that'll be all the time that I have for
this episode I'm having a lot of fun I'm
having a lot of fun with this I hope you
guys are having fun wow that's not right
oh okay it's okay guys so I hope you
guys are having fun with this I haven't
died yet so that's a good sign I'm not
just as terrible as I thought I might be
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the entities for more
cool games as I played in the past lots
of long series lots of scary games lots
of awesome games
in the description thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video